no country on earth spends as much on
health care as the United States but all
that money leaves millions without care
and millions more with care they can't
rely on the American health systems five
of all the things that divine Americans
fewer as deep or contentious as health
care the nightmare it's very hard to
wrap your head around how to navigate
the whole system I've traveled America
to look at what happens when the most
advanced economy in the world can't
guarantee health care for all we're
actually here a little earlier than we
usually get here
like a whole five minutes
I was diagnosed with breast cancer when
I was 26 and that was in 2005 at the
time I had insurance through my employer
I was working for a real estate firm at
the time they did chemotherapy for three
months and then I had a bilateral
mastectomy and then I had to continue on
one chemotherapy drug for another year
like every American when Alison Abbott
talks about health care she talks about
insurance because in America the
insurance plan you have determines the
care you receive and even with a good
plan there are bills to pay all of that
costs I want to say upwards of $20,000
out of pocket for me probably more
probably more like 30 or more imagine
that dealing with life-threatening
illnesses and all the bills and
bureaucracy super scary it's super
overwhelming insurance just sends paper
after paper after paper work for every
procedure that you're getting and I just
I was overwhelmed by all of it I didn't
know what to do with that month luckily
my mom helped me organize a system and I
would take all of my bills that came in
from the doctor's office and I would
take all of the explanation of benefits
for my insurance and I would match them
all to make sure that I was paying the
correct amount how is it fair for people
that aren't in my position that aren't
able to afford health insurance to not
be able to receive the same care that I
can because I can't afford the insurance
it's not fair so what's the answer I
don't know I can't make sense of it all
Alison recently found a small lump in
her breast she has good health cover now
but still has had to pay hundreds of
dollars for tests scans and biopsies and
hasn't yet had a diagnosis
when Barack Obama signed the Affordable
Care Act into law what was supposed to
heal the problems but what became known
as Obamacare had its own flaws his
successor has unpicked some but not all
of it despite his efforts politics has
turned health care into a divisive issue
and the American people the number one
rule when talking about health care in
America is nothing as easy as our
president recently discovered nothing in
health care is easy nothing is black and
white there's no yes or no it's all
shades of grey in situations where
consumers aren't well informed where
there's monopoly power where certain
providers can charge whatever they want
because there's nowhere else to go those
are what we call in economics market
failures in America has been weak to
address the market those on a health
care system health care in America is
staggeringly complex it's also a very
fragmented system who pays who for what
treatment and when is often not clear
even to the person receiving that
treatment even if you have health care
insurance you can lose it out of the
blue and many people rely on handouts
for any health care at all
this is the mobile medical program with
Seattle King County Public Health today
our clinic is in Capitol Hill a
neighborhood just outside of downtown
Seattle
we are parked in front of a community
meal that serves a free lunch every day
and so we are here to reach out to
people at a location where they're
already accessing services so they don't
need to make a special trip out to
access a doctor a nurse and other
services but no I have to fear
everything out of my Park
come on hundred percent so I gotta pay
for you know you're not gonna be charged
for a variety of clients this is where
they access health care as their primary
source a number of clients will come
onto the van and it's the first time
they've seen a physician in five 10 or
15 years and other clients are accessing
medical care and more emergency care
settings many of the clients that come
onto this van are employed and they just
are not currently sheltered if your
person that comes down with a serious
illness in this country and you go in
and you have Medicare or whatever and
you have private insurance we're treated
very well and I think if you're poor and
they don't really care as much they just
really don't care if you pursue it you
can find it but you're not gonna have
the best doctors are not gonna come and
say I want to be your doctor you know
they're not gonna come knocking at your
door you got to kind of search around I
think to try to find good care there's a
lot of people who are on Social Security
or disability that get bidden medical
care in this country but mostly it's
designed for the wealthy from this
mobile clinic you have to travel less
than a mile to a place that illustrates
the extremes in America Seattle's
Virginia Mason Hospital is regarded as a
world leader in transforming healthcare
they advertise themselves as pioneers in
trimming waste all across our nation
healthcare organizations and hospitals
are constantly striving to offer
exemplary care and perfect the patient
experience this hospital is mentoring
five NHS trusts in a program to improve
efficiency by cutting errors
it's not just in hospital management
where the best of American healthcare
leads the world this hospital in where
else but Silicon Valley is using what
America's tech incubator can offer to
advance treatment robots that roam the
corridors making deliveries are just
half of it the hundreds of robotic
surgeries they do here benefit from the
latest pioneering work of the tech
brains just down the road the 3d is
better than any 3d movie you're ever
seen and I've had many surgeons tell me
it's like being inside the body the
human movements of these robotic wrists
are the latest step forward industry and
Technology have actually advanced health
care to the point that patients are
having procedures done for quality of
life that they wouldn't have approached
before because they have other
healthcare issues or families that they
need to take care of our jobs that need
they need to go back to right so but
they're able to have surgery and almost
return to work two or three days after
they have their surgery well they call
the improved outcomes for patients is
why doctors here say this is an example
of what America gets right being that an
informed consumer is really important
and I think that's important in any
health care system right but I think in
the United States you have options in
regards to where you're getting your
health care which physicians you're
going to which sub specialists you're
going to so you have options in regards
to what your outcome is going to be
those choices come at a price though one
that's out of reach for many it's an
extraordinary statistic but every year
700,000 people in America go bankrupt
because of their medical bills so
September 1st 2011 was the date I was
diagnosed with breast cancer um April
3rd year 2012 was the date that my pork
came out which for me signified the end
of treatment Sonya will have the
reminders for life she also still has
the bills and considered bankruptcy
there were times that I didn't make my
medical monthly payments and if you
don't make your medical your monthly
payments then you they can bill you for
the whole thing and you can't get on a
payment plan again and it's just this
never-ending cycle Jones money now
working in a hospital call center
I'll get phone calls because I work
overnight people be like I have this in
this insurance well the emergency room
helped me so people are wanting to go to
the emergency room but they're having to
think through will they take my
insurance and will I be covered so that
I can go get this help that I need and
just that that just kind of is
astounding to me that we have to people
have to have the conversation with
themselves like I said I need help but I
need to go somewhere that looks at my
insurance
[Music]
most Americans pay for their health
insurance through their employer
millions more military veterans and the
elderly already received NHS styled
government health care yet the model of
a single-payer system for everyone is
often demonized as socialized medicine
we have the worst health care system in
the developed world most people believe
that we need a universal healthcare
system because they're suffering
campaigners want to put a universal
system for Washington state to the vote
in November it would be the country's
first it has to happen every other
developed country has figured this out I
don't know why our representatives in
Congress or our legislature can't seem
to figure it out but we're gonna apply
as much pressure as possible even if our
ballot measure fails to get the amount
of signatures where you in need or we
don't pass we're gonna apply pressure so
that they do pass this eventually thank
you so much for fighting today I believe
that we all need universal health care
is a basic human right part of living
and being able to survive in this world
there's so many things about health care
that that are absolutely tragic so for
me to say I'm not in favor of the
approach that you're taking the doesn't
mean that I don't deeply deeply care for
people but they expect resistance from
an industry that makes 65 billion
dollars a year
insurers discriminate because that's
what the profit maximizing to do is
they're not bad people the insurers
they're not evil they're just saying
look if I insure a sick I'm going to
lose money
find your health think I'm gonna make
money so I'm gonna avoid the sick guys
and sign up the healthy guys likewise
the providers in the medical system you
know if you're a great hospital and
you're the best Hospital in the area and
people are willing to pay whatever to
come to you you're in your right mind to
charge whatever you want for those
services so it's not a matter of ethics
immorality it's a matter of the market
its what the market will bear and it's a
market that by itself doesn't function
properly
it is a system of winners and losers and
a story best told by those who survived
Jonathan was diagnosed with testicular
cancer at 28 there is a strong
correlation between body and mind and
here you are just trying to survive
you're trying to get through these very
big surgeries tubes run down my nose a
catheter I couldn't move
now six years cancer-free he knows he's
lucky but his scarred by the experience
in many ways America is a global leader
but we don't even take care of our own
people let's say you have a rare form of
cancer and there's a doctor that is the
expert in it and they could keep you
alive but they're not in your health
network now all of a sudden you're
making a decision well can I afford
groceries for my children could I pay my
mortgage or should I see this doctor
I heard a story the other day about a
gentleman who couldn't afford to see the
doctor and eventually when he did it was
too late a lot of these cancer spreads
so quickly and you need to be seen as
immediately as possible and to know that
this person's passing could have been
avoided is a tragedy and I just don't
know how we change that
and that is the reality of health care
in America where some get world-class
treatment for their illness but that
same illness kills 50 people a day
because they get no treatment those who
rely on the NHS might reflect on its
70th anniversary how lucky they are not
to suffer the worst of a system like
America's but how they perhaps miss out
on some of the best of a system that is
far from caring for everyone